[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo on parle de cette semaine
d'agriculture quel modèle agricole pour
l'europe en général pour la france en
particulier
ces dernières années on s'est beaucoup
posé la question de l'avenir du
glyphosate en europe
attention autour du désherbant le plus
vendu au monde et est montée d'un cran
indispensable disent en choeur la
plupart des agriculteurs cancérogènes
probables tonnes les écologistes henri
autorisant le glyphosate pour cinq ans
en décembre dernier la commission
européenne avait aussi promis plus de
transparence dans les procédures
d'homologation des pesticides
elle a fait des propositions pour plus
de transparence on veut en parler son
côté le parlement européen a mis en
place une commission spéciale sur le
système d'autorisation des pesticides en
europe
elle a commencé son travail dans quête
bref la saga européenne sur le clip
hosatte est loin d'être terminée on va
parler avec nos invités trois invités
m'ont rejoint sur ce plateau eric
andrieu bonjour vous êtes député
européen du groupe des socialistes et
démocrates vous êtes surtout le
président de la commission poste à la
commission spéciale d'investigation sur
le système d'autorisation des pesticides
en europe commission instaurée par le
parlement européen a quelques mois c'est
aussi la reconnaissance de la bataille
que vous menez depuis longtemps pour une
alimentation plus saine respectueuse de
l'environnement des conditions de
travail des agriculteurs face à vous
rangez luc delahaye bonjour bonjour les
députés européens du groupe du parti
populaire européen en france vous êtes
membre des républicains vous êtes aussi
membre de la commission environnement du
parlement européen vous aviez voté en
faveur du renouvellement du glyphosate
pour cinq ans vous êtes membre de la
commission peste et je rappelle par
ailleurs que vous êtes agricultrice
merci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
enfin également membre de cette
commission sur l'autorisation des
pesticides en europe michèle rivasi
bonjour vous êtes députée européenne du
groupe des verts ici au parlement
européen vous n'aviez pas caché votre
déception décembre dernier après le vote
européen en faveur d'une nouvelle
autorisation pour cinq ans du cliff
hosatte vous aviez voté contre pour vous
ce sont les lobbys 1 qui ont gagné à
compte la santé de la population vent
parler de ces lobbys on va en parler
mais d'abord l'actualité c'est la
riposte de bruxelles au désastreux
feuilleton du cliff hosatte la
commission européenne annonce m
ri de propositions pour améliorer la
sécurité alimentaire et tenter de
redonner confiance aux consommateurs
après les nombreux scandales notamment
la polémique l'ifo that en gros qu'il y
ait plus de transparence alors quelles
sont ses propositions on regarde et on
réagit juste après le glyphosate un
dossier qui a déchiré l'union européenne
pendant des années il y a ceux qui
disent que cet herbicide et cancérogènes
et veulent son interdiction définitive
et il ya ceux qui disent qu'on ne peut
pas faire sans on a besoin de pesticides
dans notre agriculture productiviste
en europe les pays bas ou la hongrie
était pour renouveler l'autorisation du
pesticide controversé pour quinze ans
qu'on la france ou l'allemagne voulait
une autorisation pour trois ans au final
après d'interminables discussions le
clip hosatte sera autorisée pour cinq
ans dans l'union européenne
il a eu du lobbying des deux côtés côté
industriel et côté ong de l'opacité dans
les procédures et du conflit d'intérêts
le souci vient des études scientifiques
sur lesquelles s'appuient les autorités
sanitaires européennes au mondial et les
experts de la commission européenne
ces études sont souvent introuvables non
consultables ou quand elles le sont
c'est partiellement
cela nourrit le soupçon sur des études
souvent financées par les industriels
eux mêmes
le propose la commission européenne la
commission propose que désormais tous
les citoyens puissent avoir accès aux
études scientifiques
cela passerait par un registre qui
recenserait toutes les études qui ont
été commandés qu'elle soit favorable ou
défavorable aux industriels la
commission demande aussi de disposer
d'un pouvoir pour commander une nouvelle
étude scientifique plusieurs chansons
concernés les produits phytosanitaires
les ogm ou les additifs alimentaires
est ce une victoire pour les ong pour
les ong
si le minimum syndical elle voudrait que
ces études scientifiques ne soient plus
financé comme aujourd'hui par les
industriels mais par l'union européenne
problème cela coûte très cher
ces propositions de la commission doit
maintenant être discutées et votées par
les 28 chefs d'état et de gouvernement
et aussi par les députés européens
un long débat en perspective
justement la commission peste le
parlement européen a mis en place une
commission spéciale sur le système
d'autorisation des pesticides en europe
la peste elle a commencé son travail d'
enquête il ya quelques jours à bruxelles
en auditionnant plus de la commission
directeur exécutif de l'efsa l'agencé
européenne de sécurité des aliments
vous êtes le président de cette
commission nous allait enquêter sur quoi
exactement
on va équité si vous des sur toutes les
étapes de la procédure d'autorisation
donc des molécules c'est de vous voir
régulièrement ne collectivement et dans
l'ensemble des groupes participent à ces
travaux
comment nous pouvons garantir que demain
lorsque les cd rom un bon de manger des
aliments vont respirer l'air boire de
l'eau mais ce soit exemple de toute
molécule dangereuse pour la santé
humaine et donc étape par étape on va
voir qu'est ce qui dysfonctionne
aujourd'hui le poids de l'industrie par
rapport au public ça a été dit
aujourd'hui je ne vais pas faire une
révélation et donner une information par
exemple qui nous pose deux questions
lorsque l'industriel travaille sur une
molécule investi beaucoup d'argent sur
nos molécules c'est l'industriel qui va
choisir l'état membre qui va devoir
donner un avis sur la dangerosité au nom
de la molécule est ce que ça au nom de
la démocratie
donc c'est tout à fait acceptable ou
faut-il changer les procédures est ce
qu'aujourd'hui les choix des études qui
s'en fait par exemple donc par le public
l'efsa où les cas donc doit être fait
différemment
est ce qu'aujourd'hui dont les modèles
d'autorisation le poids du public et des
lobbys du privé pardon et des lobbys
doit être amendé ou contrôler je crois
qu'il ya un vrai souci de démocratie
l'enjeu il est commun il est partagé par
tous c'est celui de la santé humaine et
aujourd'hui il faut voir dans quelle
mesure nous en tant que co législateur
nous pouvons organiser le système
d'autorisation pour cette semaine soit
garanti angélique delahaye vous étiez
plutôt contre l'instauration de cette
commission denquête c'était quoi vos
réticences moi ma réticence et de
dépenser correctement l'argent public
c'est la première de nos responsabilités
et c'est des travaux qui vous pouvait
être fait par la commission
environnement
une autre décision a été prise mois la
santé humaine bienvenus je considère ce
quand on une commission a vocation à
faire un travail elle doit le faire
en l'occurrence ça n'était pas le cas
donc je me suis rangé à l'avis général
qui consistait à dire après tout
allons-y vérifions g c'est la
proposition d'ailleurs que je fais au
président de mon groupe en 10 ans après
tout allons-y regardons ce qui se passe
et puis on parle beaucoup de molécules
mois ce qui m'embête beaucoup dans tout
ça c'est qu'on ne parle pas des produits
commerciaux qui font l'objet d'un
certain nombre d'additifs qui eux
d'ailleurs sont souvent source de
problèmes en matière de santé humaine
et là il ya une vraie une vraie
problématique des sans droits qui ne
sont pas ne sont pas et qui ne sont pas
de la responsabilité de l'europe puisse
peser chaque état membre qui autorise
élèves ça nous a appris une chose très
intéressante
justement l'autre jour à l'occasion
d'auditions par la commission spéciale
pesticides sur un produit comme le
glyphosate sur une molécule comme le
glyphosate
la france a autorisé plus de 600
produits commerciaux dans le même temps
la hollande
elle n'en a autorisé que 60 donc au
moins je me dis que manifestement c'est
une question de santé publique
il faut aussi qu'on s'intéresse aux
produits commerciaux et pas uniquement
aux molécules parce que d'ailleurs nous
avons fait retirer c'est pour ça que
j'ai voté le texte pour la
réautorisation du milf êtes parce que
nous y avons amené beaucoup
d'amendements qui ont restreint le champ
de l'utilisation de ce produit et nous y
avons nous avons demandé l'interdiction
d'un confort mullan qui lui est
manifestement cancérigènes puisque ça a
été prouvé par des études scientifiques
donc notre responsabilité c'est d'aller
au bout de la réflexion et de ne pas
regarder que le plan européen
mais ce que font aussi les états membres
moi je suis assez d'accord avec ce qu'a
dit eric tout à l'heure qu'un industriel
choisissent une agence moi je me demande
au nom de quoi
par contre il faut que les agences qui
sont choisis on est la garantie qu'elle
lisait la capacité à analyser
correctement et à produire les études
qui nous permettrons à nos colonisateurs
de nous appuyer sur des choses sérieuses
pour garantir la santé s'il ya quelque
part une faillite ou six dans l'
expertise européenne dans cette histoire
on a d'un côté les experts européens qui
disent n'y a pas de problème avec le
pivot at il est pas cancérogène c'est le
cas de l'efsa l'agencé européenne de
sécurité des aliments ou laïcs à
l'agencé européenne des produits les
produits chimiques
à ceux qui disent le contraire c'est
cancérigène c'est le cas de l'om est
choisi tout à l'heure on parlait de la
transparence des études scientifiques
dans le cas de l'om est toutes les
études son public
dans le cas de l'efsa il y avait
soixante quatorze études financées par
les industriels qui n'étaient pas
publics
donc ça déjà voyez ça peut expliquer la
différence
après c'est quelles études on prend en
compte et quelles études ont autant que
c'est à dire qu'on estime qu'elles n'ont
pas la méthode objets etc
c'est l'industriel que choisie et là
pour revenir sur ce que tu disais c'est
que il faut avoir la garantie que les
études sont correctement fait comprends
qu'on des études universitaires et pas
que les études des industriels et qu'en
dernier ressort si à polémique
il faudrait que l'europe ait les moyens
de commandité une étude en même temps
quand on voit le produit final aux
agences nationales
grosso modo en europe il ya trois
agences qui tienne la route il ya la
française yelle anglaise il ya
l'allemande est le problème c'est que
sur 600 produits sur les ce qu'on
appelle les cons formulant mais ça
demande un boulot considérable et je
suis persuadé et ça on va pouvoir le
voir au niveau de la commission que les
agences donne un feu vert alors qu'ils
ne savent pas tous les causses formulant
qui sont qui sont me voyez dans le
produit est donc moins à l'heure
actuelle je peux vous dire je n'ai pas
la garantie que la sécurité sanitaire
des citoyens européens est garanti soit
c'est l'europe qui a les moyens et
canalise des produits mais on peut pas
laisser à chaque état man x c'est pas la
hongrie la roumanie la pologne ou le
portugal qui va être capable d'analyser
voyez énormément de confort mullan dans
les produits donc quelque part c'est une
façon d'autoriser des produits sans
avoir les évaluations scientifiques le
niveau international vous allez pouvoir
auditionner monsanto bande et j'espère
bien il faut dès aujourd'hui faut savoir
garde de jour
la cour d'appel de californie a confirmé
que la molécule du glyphosate était
cancérigène
donc il faut on peut pas ne pas s'être
déroulé le glyphosate il est pas que
français il est pas qu européen il est
pas qu internationale dont nous avons
demandé nous effectivement à faire mais
moi j'ai proposé à ce qu'on ait une
émission faite donc aux états unis
donc ça a été refusé par la majorité des
groupes de musique va siffler mais là
dessus mais comment dire à trouver une
formule pour pouvoir entendre écouter
les parties prenantes mais je pensais
que c'était important aussi que nous
allions allait aller coûte 2 après la
démocratie s'exprime donc de chacun vote
en conscience mais par isa je donne un
exemple sur la question du glyphosate si
vous voulez un peu puisqu'on parle de ce
sujet là l'état d'en porter qui a été
choisi par monsanto c'est l'allemagne
donc et le bfr
mais il ya un an et à 1 court à porter
elle savez vous qui est en cours à
porter donc sur la mort des deux livres
c'est la slovaquie au milieu d'un de le
dire il ya trois agences en europe qui
sont reconnus pour leurs performances
l'agent la france l'allemagne et le
royaume uni pourquoi aujourd'hui on a eu
un court reportage était la slovaquie
alors qu'à priori ya pas une vraie
compétence en la matière c'est un sujet
qui n'est pas mineure parce qu'on traite
justement besoin d'une molécule qui est
importante parce qu'elle est utilisé
massivement par la profession juridique
de la haine il ya des agriculteurs qui
disent nous le glyphosate ne peut pas
faire sans ou comment faire d'abord faut
savoir à quoi ça sert ça sert à
désherber et donc on a engagé les
agriculteurs depuis un certain nombre
d'années dans des techniques pour ne
plus émettre de gaz à effet de serre
pour mieux respecter la biodiversité de
leur sol et donc il ne laboure plus et
donc on ne vous ne la bourrée pas qu'est
ce qui se passe et mail il ya des
mauvaises herbes qui poussent et quand
vous voulez mettre en place votre
culture et bal à la capacité à germer
correctement parce qu'elle est étouffé
par ses mauvaises herbes donc avant
d'implanter la culture qu'est ce qu'ils
font ils passent un coup de glyphosate
de façon à nettoyer le sol et derrière
ils peuvent implanter effectivement leur
culture qu'est ce qu'il faut faire je
veux bien trois ans en france on
retrouve et attendent un produit de
substitution - ça fait plus de dix ans
que je milite pour qu'on mette
massivement des moyens financiers sur la
table pour accompagner la recherche le
développement dans des mesures
alternatives
j'étais la première professionnelle en
milieu agricole a créé un groupement
d'intérêt scientifique en france avec
l'inra pour trouver des alternatives à
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires donc c'est assez
difficile de me taxer d'être pro
produits phytosanitaires pour autant je
suis quelqu'un de pragmatique et je
pense qu'on ne peut pas mettre les
agriculteurs dans l'impasse où d'autres
acteurs économiques va moi j'aimerais
savoir comment la sncf 2
va dire désherber les rails de chemin de
fer qui passe le long de mon
exploitation
parce que quelquefois quand il passe du
glyphosate un peu large
je peux vous dire que mes salades à côté
elle n'aime pas beaucoup et en règle
générale -2 pacbi folates sur les
salades qui ont le pouvoir les récolter
je crois qu'il ya un moment il ya une
nécessité de faire évoluer les choses et
ça moi je suis je serai toujours très
proactive mais il ya un principe de
réalité et donc tant qu'on n'a pas
d'alternative
eh bien il faut il trouver des moyens
c'est pour ça que j'ai eu vraiment
parlement pour qu'on puisse réduire au
maximum l'utilisation de ce produit tant
que demain on n'a pas une étude qui est
en capacité de nous prouver de façon
indubitable que il faut changer les
choses allaient direction l'italie
maintenant au nord du pays mal sv nosta
un village agricole
là bas les habitants ont décidé
d'interdire carrément les pesticides le
slogan c'est un peu un plus de chimie
dans les campagnes on regarde le
reportage de françois goulard et ont
réagi juste après
[Musique]
les montagnes imposantes veille sur ce
petit village du nord de l'italie a mal
sv nosta se déroule le combat de david
contre goliath
les habitants ont décidé d'interdire les
pesticides envers et contre tout lo sé
sak trahissent de la boire sans crainte
johannes freineur se battent depuis
vingt ans pour en finir avec les
produits chimiques menacé de mort par
les agriculteurs
il a persévéré jusqu'à obtenir
l'organisation d'un référendum il ya
trois ans c'est que les gens ont été
nombreux à participer
ils ont préparé ce référé pendant deux
ans on a fait venir deux les experts du
monde entier toxicologue pharmacologue
médeçin l'environnement agriculteurs bio
et on expliquer tout le monde même aux
touristes nos arguments
à la fin on a fait ce référendum
populaire et on a gagné largement avec
76 % des votants qui ont dit oui nous
croyons à cette voie là désormais la
commune est la seule de la vallée de la
région et même du pays à avoir banni les
pesticides
johannes est aussi le pharmacien de
ville pendant des années il a vu ses
concitoyens tombé malade à cause des
épandages dans les champs aujourd'hui
après trois ans d'un environnement plus
sain les changements sont visibles
non
on travaille avec une pédiatre de
castelbello un village juste à côté au
milieu des vergers
on observe un nombre d'enfants malades
beaucoup plus important là-bas ici à
malaise vers un site à il y a beaucoup
moins das médaille d'argent
nous nous battons pour que notre village
ne devienne pas comme ses voisins mal sv
nosta est désormais un îlot au milieu
d'une marée de produits chimiques
autour du village pousse des milliers
d'hectares de pommiers arrosés de
pesticides plus de 30 fois par an en
moyenne et même dans le village il y a
des réfractaires à la nouvelle loi
gunther vanover en fait les frais
éleveur bio à malaise depuis plus de dix
ans il soupçonne son voisin de continuer
à traiter ces pommes pas de chance
l'éleveur est élu à la mairie est en
charge des contrôles désormais c'est 600
euros damende à payer si des produits
sont trouvés dans les champs les
agriculteurs qui utilisent encore des
pesticides se moque de ce qu'on fait
pense que rien ne va changer mais ils ne
sont que 20 25 sur plus d'une centaine
au total le référendum va aider à faire
bouger les choses mais il faudra du
temps pour faire évoluer les mentalités
tout le monde pense encore que sans
pesticides sa récolte est foutu
une idée enraciné dans l'esprit des
agriculteurs et qui arrange bien les
multinationales productrice de pommes
aucune d'entre elles n'a voulu répondre
à nos demandes d'interview
à quelques kilomètres de là au pied des
montagnes cet agronome et c'est de
montrer aux agriculteurs comment se
passer des produits chine
ils disposent dans leurs champs des
pièges pour les insectes ravageurs
délia bull terrier la terre peuvent
représenter un problème pour les
semences de maïs en fonction du nombre
de larves capturé on décide si une
parcelle est à risque et si on doit la
traiter ou non
nos recherches montrent que dans
seulement 1% des cas les insectes sont
vraiment nuisible et un traitement
chimique est nécessaire le risque de
perdre sa récolte est donc un film mais
le scientifique a décidé de créer avec
une association d'agriculteurs une
assurance à bas prix 3 4 euros de
l'hectare pour rassurer les agriculteurs
dubitative sur les cinquante mille
hectares couverts par l'assurance nous
avons remboursé moins de 1 % des
surfaces en trois ans ce faible
pourcentage des mondes qui lie à une
utilisation démesurée des pesticides les
agriculteurs recherchent la sécurité
même si le risque n'est pas réel
il y a deux effets positifs a transformé
sa production
d'abord ou réduit les traitements donc
l'impact sur l'environnement est plus
faible et ensuite on diminue les coûts
de l'entreprise
cette économie sera peut-être l'argument
qui fera changer les pratiques agricoles
en italie le pays a déjà le plus grand
nombre d'agriculteurs bio de rang
[Musique]
voilà portage en italie de françois
goulet michèle rivasi quand vous voyez
cette initiative vous dit quoi que de
chimie dans les campagnes ce sont des
rêveurs où c'est possible mais c'est
possible ce qui est assez amusant
d'ailleurs ce qu'il a fallu un
référendum voyez pour faire en sorte à
ce que ce village disent on utilise plus
de pesticides ce que j'aurai dire quand
même aussi en france c'est que il ya des
villes où il ya zéro pesticide et au
début on nous disait des villes voyez on
met plus de pesticides dans les terrains
de foot on met plus de pesticides dans
les jardins etc
ça ça existe déjà on nous disait au
début c'est impossible
et puis on le fait ça demande une
formation et au niveau de l'agriculture
on le fait aussi moi je suis d'un
département la drogue qui est le
département le plus bio de france
et bien moi je vois plein de jeunes
agriculteurs qui utilisent une
technologie innovante
parce que sa demande d'une technologie
ça demande plus d'observations quand il
y avait la ferme du glyphosate
c'était rapide ont balancé du glyphosate
loyer pour désherber et ont gagné du
temps là ça demande des assolements ça
demande une autre façon de fonctionner
et ça je pense qu' il faudra passer au
bio parce que si on veut jouer sur la
santé c'est quand même des milliards
économisés sur la sécurité sociale et
c'est surtout un environnement où il ya
une biodiversité
c'est ça l'enjeu et qu'on voit
l'organisation des nations unies il dit
on pourra ne pourra nourrir la planète
que si on selon dans le bio avec la
permaculture avec loyer une agriculture
qui développe énormément les écosystèmes
où il ya de meilleurs rendements que ces
immenses exploitations agricoles où on
mettait plein de pesticides
le quadrille on doit se réorienter vers
un autre modèle agricole vers vers le
bio et oui je crois que le reportage est
en cela très bien fait la question qui
est posée à travers le reportage dans le
lit c'est une question de choix de
société
tout le monde de le production doit
accompagner ce choix de société là est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on doit continuer à le
penser
je crois qu'on est tous d'accord pour
dire changer de modèle aujourd'hui à
dépenser l'agriculture qu'avec une seule
vision celle du marché doré de marché
libre donc voilà à l'international on
voit bien que ça répond pas à moi
j'arrive d'une mission au brésil
vous savez c'est pas comparable quand on
a des stratégies qui sont là pour
déforester sur les supports mettre de
l'engrais
mettre les cultures de maïs maître du
glyphosate finit par du soja
on n'est pas sur ce modèle là je crois
qu'on est tous d'accord là dessus donc
il faut effectivement à partir d'un
choix d'un modèle de société
trouver des alternatives dans le bios en
est une mais aujourd'hui faut être
réaliste c'est 5 6% de l'agriculture
française et européenne donc il faut
faire progresser la conscience
collective
je veux dire il faut tendre vers faire
avancer la cause collective des
agriculteurs conventionnels
il ya ce qu'on appelle un des systèmes
intégrés donc ils font appel à des
pratiques de mixte qui aujourd'hui
existe qui forme d'épreuves qui on donne
des résultats
il faut progresser à la fois c'est
interdit peut-être chimiques de ça il
faut en discuter mais également sur les
pratiques agronomiques tel que cela a
été montré là on a parlé beaucoup des
insecticides
il y à déjà dans la viticulture moi je
suis un pays viticoles des moyens
aujourd'hui sur le biocontrôle pas que
l'arboriculture les fruits et légumes
d'engrais viticulture on a des pratiques
aujourd'hui biologiques qui permettent
d'avoir des résultats excellents du
point de vue agronomique économiques et
environnementales et du coup sur la
santé humaine
je pense qu'il faut progresser et
cheminer ensemble pour garantir
rapidement maintenant donc la qualité
des avions qui la commet souvent il faut
des interdictions pourquoi il est léger
stress que voyez s'il n'y a pas
d'interdiction et on continue et on
remet un génie de la cave est une
réalité économique on constate chez
pesticides vrai chocolat grand jour en
europe que l'interdiction c'est pas
suffisant il faut la citation et les
agriculteurs enfin moi j'en fais paru la
transition moi j'en fais partie ça fait
des années que je suis passé à
l'agriculture raisonnée c'est à dire
qu'on est plus en agriculture
conventionnelle mais on est encore pas
en bio je ne sais pas si j'arriverai à
faire du bio un jour parce qu'il ya un
environnement non c'est pas tant un
problème de coût évidemment qu'il ya un
problème de coût quand vous avez besoin
de plus de manoeuvre au coût de la main
d'oeuvre en france par rapport à
d'autres pays et prendre de demande que
d'offre
s'il ya un problème mais la vraie à mon
avis plus que l'interdiction
le vrai moteur ça va être en tous les
cas moi je le constate chez beaucoup de
mes collègues comme ça a été pour moi la
question économique
pourquoi on est passés à l'agriculture
raisonnée
parce que il ya un certain nombre de
techniques d'innovation
sont venus remplacer des éléments qui
étaient des pv le mans de coûts nous ça
fait 30 ans que en production sous serre
on est en lutte biologique intégrée où
on n'utilise plus de pesticides
sauf que on est dans un habitat qui
permet de réguler aussi tous les
ravageurs enfin un certain nombre de
ravageurs en tant que la garonne pour
autant il ya des questions
d'environnement qui font que et bien il
ya des pression parasitaire qui sont
différentes d'un endroit sur l'eau moi
je crois que le premier moteur c'est la
conscience collective des agriculteurs
et je trouve qu'on a une image quand
même quelque peu erronée de la réalité
de l'agriculture
il suffit d'aller au salon de
l'agriculture à paris pour voir quelles
sont les nouvelles technologies
utilisées par les agriculteurs
est ce que dit michel est à mon avis
très vrai aux états unis ils les deux
points de moins en moins en france parce
que le revenu des agriculteurs est ce
qu'il est on ça a été dit dans le
reportage
tout ce que vous dépendez pas dans votre
champ c'est du revenu en plus donc
aujourd'hui avec l'élévation du niveau
de formation des agriculteurs avec les
nouvelles technologies avec les
innovations avec les a aucune sommateurs
aussi mais c'est la première des
exigences moi je produis pour un
consommateur je produis pas comme ça
dans la pure lui ou pour jeter un
produit donc mon produit faut qu'il
réponde à un marché et aujourd'hui on
voit bien il ya des pays où l'exigence
est montée d'un cran et bien les
agriculteurs savoir c'est sûrement un
des acteurs économiques et un des
milieux économiques qui s'est le plus
adapté à la demande des consoles wii
mais il a fallu un vrai débat quand même
la conscience collective progresse dans
les agriculteurs saf et grands tous les
métiers si vous voulez entendre ce
gâchis
l'ancien régime de la junte est parti et
puis hier ce qu'il faut amener
aujourd'hui je vous dire là le 28 à une
décision importante sur la question des
néonicotinoïdes moi je milite pour comme
la commission ne propose d'interdire
trois néonicotinoïdes tueur d'abeilles
j'ai encore y est rude tweetbot aux
dires de certains agriculteurs de
l'aisne en dit attention il veut tuer
les fourmis mais on ne peut pas comment
dire assimilé les pollinisateurs donc et
les fourmis faye un problème de
conscience dont il faut faire un travail
comme vous le faites d'ailleurs elles
ont le rôle
graissez je voulais progresser donc dans
ce cheminement donc pour tendre vers une
règle dur donc celle qui garantissait la
qualité alimentaire auprès des comptes
dit c'est le travail que vous faites ou
trois lettres les agriculteurs en
situation de concurrence avec les
produits juste se ghettoïser la
transition de soins coordonnés au niveau
européen du bio il ait pas de
concurrence déloyale
mais les algériens mais avec l'extérieur
de l'europe si c'est pour ça qu'il faut
que la pac accompagne la transition il
faut des moyens dédiés ça a été dit on
va proposer au scrabble rist a permis
d'évoluer dans ces pratiques
il faut réglementation il faut l
incitation à l'évasion et il faut aimer
la nature
exactement et la somme qu'elle et
l'agriculteur qui n'émet la nature aussi
ça le mot de la fin sera le mot de la
fin en termine par notre rubrique de
fact checking une députée la république
en marche affirmé à la télévision que le
système universitaire français
accessible à tous constituait une
exception en europe sur le plan mondial
mais qu'en est il réellement c'est
checkpoint préparer aujourd'hui par
ambroise carton l'accès à l'université
en europe
en france tous les bacheliers ont le
droit de s'inscrire à l'université
les libertés unique au monde selon la
députée en marche
coralie dubost universités françaises
permet l'accès pour tous aux études et 7
une exception en europe et à l'étranger
defour venir alors l'université ouverte
à tous mythe ou réalité
la liberté de choisir ses études
universitaires est inscrit dans la loi
française
seule condition avoir son bac
mais dans les faits les filières les
plus populaires tels que l'éducation
physique ou le droit sont saturés
certaines universités ont donc procédé à
un tirage au sort ces dernières années
pour éviter cette situation le
gouvernement a lancé parcours sup une
plateforme chargés d'orienter des futurs
étudiants
l'objectif savais pas que l'université
dix noms soit l'université accepte
l'étudiant ce soit elle lui impose de
suivre un parcours adapté
mais au fait ça se passe comment dans
les autres pays européens ont résumé il
ya ceux qui font office une sélection à
l'entrée des études le royaume uni
l'espagne la suède ou encore l'allemagne
par exemple et ceux qui sont plus
ouverts c'est le cas de la france et de
la belgique dans ce pays n'importe qui
peut s'inscrire à l'université après
avoir réussi ses études secondaires
sauf dans certaines filières président
et qui impose en examen d'entrée dans
tous les cas être un bon étudiant ne
suffit pas il faut aussi avoir de
l'argent en france les frais
d'inscription sont très bas mais tous
les étudiants n'ont pas droit à une
bourse qu'ils sont donc 46% à travailler
pour payer leurs études
mais la palme du cursus le plus cher
revient au royaume uni où la première
année dans une université publique est
facturé plus de 10 millions l'université
pour tous en france une exception
mondiale
si on met de côté le banques de placer
le coût des études parfois décourageant
et plutôt vrai voilà c'est la fin europe
hebdo merci à vous tous trois d'être
venus débattre avec nous c'était
passionnant merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis bonne chute des programmes sur
les chaînes parlementaires et la rtbf
bail
[Musique]
demain dans telle étoile info laurence
sayeh porte-parole des républicains sera
l'invité de public sénat et de la presse
quotidienne régionale territoire d'infos
présenté par cyril viguier demain à 8
heures en direct sur public sénat